les frontières entre ces mondes
commencent à s'estomper
quand vous êtes paralysés par la peur
lorsque vous êtes impuissant à cause
d'elle comme un petit enfant alors la
porte s'ouvre et un esprit apparaît
alors je voudrais offrir 30 mille
dollars à la première personne qui peut
me donner la preuve définitive tu vis
après le marre comme un fantôme où
quelque chose dont je pourrais pas
douter tu penses que tu vas trouver
quelque chose
c'est du grand vraiment né ce parc vo
souffrait de problèmes car nous vous
avez une mauvaise circulation sanguine
mais c'est quoi ça il fait la queue pour
les montagnes russes mais en quelque
sorte
ils sont en colère en ce moment ils
n'aiment pas que vous seriez n'a une
fois tu auras but que se fait montrer tu
seras un peu dans le cercle restreint
sur ce truc
eh bien tu sera ouvert à ça à eux
parce que vous voyez d'autres personnes
que moi tu sais déjà que c'est réel
par contre aucune chose horrible s'est
produite les as pas encore maintenant
mais ça ne s'était pas
c'est tout
[Musique]
tu me crois maintenant
je te crois maintenant
[Musique]
et